Her low freak bitches.
Hey y'all.
I got a white hat on because I'm a good
guy.
You want me to do it?
The black hat now you want me to do,
I'm the lack of a white hat sort of a
guy according to my record label.
So the Jeremy Pivot down there at yelp.
Oh,
does he have a glass in his hand or his?
No,
that's something.
Just know they changed outfits.
There was a makeup lady,
you know what I mean?
It's just cute for Sutherland.
Oh,
what's this?
No Cigar.
Cute.
There's no fucking cigar.
Yeah,
him and Deniro.
Hey.
What the fuck is this Kiefer?
Listen,
Pussy.
You're scared to pull it off.
Look at Kramer James Bond.
No.
Sukar go into a Kramer's over,
by the way,
Best James Bond by far,
right?
Daniel Craig.
No one's even close.
Yeah,
he's the coolest.
Oh,
Kramer Kramer.
It's lovable.
You know he's thinking when he's holding
that cigar.
I love black people.
Yes.
He's thinking he's thinking of saving.
That word rhymes with bigger
Danny Devito.
He's got something going on.
What is he doing?
He's lighting it.
Manny too many takes there.
I know there was more than one take on
it.
I can pull it off.
It's dead on the inside.
I don't care.
This is good for publicity.
This is good for my image.
When I smoke as their God gives you the
feeling of prosperity.
I live in a mansion in the palisades and
I fucked my maid Dai
gum inside them or don't give your woman
with me.
I come inside her as well.
That's why his cover works.
Adrian Brody,
I'm just sitting here wondering what
happened.
You're right,
arnold is the perfect person that sees
to investors to loan.
Seems fairly candid photos but I'm
worried there was too many takes.
I'm worried they took several takes.
Now you spitting into that thing.
What's going on here?
We got mom drinking Copenhagen.
What does that shit?
Yeah,
Copenhagen.
What's the deal with that?
Explain that to me.
What does that do for you?
I've never been involved.
I have no experience in this.
I chewed tobacco once when I was a kid
cause I read huckleberry Finn,
they give you,
they give you a head high threw up.
I started extra salivating and I felt
like shit,
I don't know.
It was it good.
I like it.
I'm gonna try something that give it a
go.
What do you do with it?
Take a little bump.
Put under your lip bump.
A little pinch,
like a cocaine style bump.
Now we've never done that either.
I'd go less is less than what you asked
plenty for you.
Is that too much?
That's good.
Okay.
Where do you put it?
Anywhere you put any love you want.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's going to start to burn a little bit
bigger cancer immediately.
I don't think so.
I mean,
now you shouldn't.
That doesn't taste bad.
No,
it's like wintergreen done.
It's been the right one because you do
not,
I repeat.
Do not want to drink juice.
Spit.
That is a fucking day gone bad.
Well,
one of the guys who worked in UFC who
was a,
uh,
Jamie's laughing cause of chewing,
it looks ridiculous.
Why does it look ridiculous?
You're going to get a supervisee high.
It's gonna be great.
I get messages every day from people
that lost a hundred pounds right there
feeling healthy.
The problem is we're dealing with
propaganda and you can do one or two
things.
You could either just say,
well,
you know,
this is this,
this,
I think I swallowed all that tobacco.
Yeah.
It's all gone.
Oh yeah.
I was wondering why I'm so high.
You got Tobacco on it.
It's gone.
I don't have it.
Yeah.
Swallowed up.
I had a boy,
I don't know what I'm doing.
All right too.
And drank and swat.
Right.
So he makes a ton of videos and puts
them on instagram.
Chris Brown.
Yeah.
Of Him given his side of what things are
and then he's,
he's keeping it real essentially.
Yeah.
It videos and it's his,
and he's smoking a cigarette.
It's very sketch.
So they didn't hold on him.
They arrested him and then the fuck out
of them.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know if they kept them,
but I mean they went in and they booked
him for assault with a deadly weapon or
attempted assault with a deadly weapon.
Is that what it is?
How long until he's saying that the cops
were roughing him up.
I'm sure they have video footage of
everything.
They wouldn't be crazy.
It'd be crazy not to.
Yeah,
something like that.
Like Chris Brown,
like fuck is under age cousin and then
piss on somebody.
No,
that was our Kelly.
You can find like three different black
people.
I don't know who fuck their cousin Kelly
was peanut people didn't he used to put
with this lately and molest them?
No,
that's the other guy.
That's bill cosby.
Oh,
got it.
Jesus Christ.
And that crazy like,
what the fuck man,
I can't tell black people heart and just
realize that you confused r Kelly and
Chris Brown is that bad.
And they close.
They're off by like 15,
20 years.
What if one of them is our age?
Our Kelly is our eyes.
He's 49.
And when did he play basketball?
He didn't play basketball.
He's a singer.
A singer.
Got It.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know any of his songs other than
the really hilarious ones.
Okay.